Caitlyn Jenner wants you to know her  stance on same-sex marriage at first I  was not for it I made I thought I'm a  traditionalist I'm older than most  people in the audience you know I mean I  kind of like tradition and you know it's  always been a man and a woman and I'm  thinking I don't quite get it  that was Caitlyn back in 2015 on The  Ellen DeGeneres Show but now in a new  sit-down with Diane Sawyer set to air  Friday night Kate says this I am 100%  behind gay marriage let's clear that up  right now and I am 100% for for gay  marriage because I think two years ago  you said there was an evolving process  what's your wife's yeah but I am get it  straight I am all for Caitlyn also opens  up about her politics in the new  interview yes I did vote for Trump but  here's the deal breaker with the  Republican Party and the deal-breaker is  you mess with my community you do the  wrong thing with our community you don't  give us equality and a fair shot I'm  coming after you